you know how you were saying from the
beginning of this show if not the
beginning of this
uh season how the clippers had
completely blown it
by mortgaging their entire future for
what amounts to a two-year experiment
because both paul george and kawhi
leonard could walk after this year
and then of course they collapse against
the nuggets but
i don't even know if it's a collapse
maybe they actually just
reverted to who they are and who they
were always
going to be based on what i'm reading in
the athletic today this explosive story
um and then you go to uh and then doc
rivers of course gets fired and
ends up in philadelphia i don't know how
much you've gotten through
this athletic piece but it's a lot here
but just a couple of things to
to point out and it comes back to the
guy
who for the most part got a pass
and that's kawhi leonard paul george
rightfully so
he got it doc rivers was the fall guy
okay
a lot of people got blamed kawhi based
off his
two championships and two finals mvps
kind of skated for the most part and
also i think he skated because he's so
quiet
but just because he's quiet i mean he
you know people don't people don't throw
what he wants
here we go hey hey you know what was a
lie from the best man what was that
i'm the best man you've done dirt too
you're stuck just saying caught you yet
you'll start just saying
private space for his pregame routine
even if that space occupied the female
staffers locker room
okay he and paul george own personal
security guards and trainers
they had the power over the team's
practice and travel schedule leading
teammates to believe that leonard
canceled practice multiple times
leonard we knew this allowed to live in
san diego and commute made him late for
team
flights that's leonard and paul george
didn't speak to the media until at least
45 minutes after the game concluded a
lot of times
which left teammates to speak for him
to speak yeah they believe that
teammates believed which is
look even if it wasn't true this is what
they believed which is just as bad
that leonard and paul george were able
to pick and choose when they played
sometimes games entirely other times
they accept it and decline
playing time it goes on uh teammates
accepted it for better or worse
but there was a sentiment among certain
teammates of what if you accomplished
paul george in the playoffs
to deserve this and here's the biggest
quote and it goes on also
indict marcus morris when he came over
to trade quote if you were to ask all 15
players individually who the leader was
you get a lot of different answers one
league source said again this is all
reported
this is all alleged but nonetheless it
points back to kawhi leonard because
like as great as as brilliant as he is
as great as
as he is is he one of those guys that is
incapable of being the real
true unquestioned leader
of a championship team there's a
difference between finals mvp
that's right a defensive player there's
a difference between are you the leader
of the championship team
because this this this is oh i'm sorry i
don't absolve this person
it's a kawhi leonard issue and quite
frankly it's a steve ballmer issue
because i don't care and it goes back to
who was it my man uh
not sean elliott man bruce bowen getting
oh yeah getting fired getting fired
before he was even
because yes right because of the
possibility that he might have
before kawhi got there and criticized
how about
yes how about doc taking the fine
on purpose on your former network
on espn sitting there with
magic sitting right next to him he said
yeah you know hey doc
who's kawhi might remind you of he said
jordan
i'm like dude i know what you do
doc i know what you're doing you're
great at it i know exactly what you're
doing
oh yeah you know he he he does all this
and at this point kawhi wasn't on the
roster but he was trying to get him
there
he was fine for tampering rightfully so
but he got kawhi
what i say it's not worth it this is the
kind of stuff
that that i'm referring to and i think i
got to revise because i
i got a little everybody's got to be
moved off their talking points including
me
so i got this little thing at this
little thing when people ask me okay do
i like super teams mike i said
well if you tell me you don't like super
teams you don't like the nba the nba was
built on super teams george viking had a
super team
uh red hour back built super teams jerry
went to the whole thing i got my whole
little spiel
i get i get rolling too but
they had super teams that were still
mindful of the team construct
if you're going to have a super team and
somebody's going to come in and say
they're above it
then it's not going to work and and
that's what's happening with the
that's what happened with the clippers
and that's why the clippers that's one
of the many reasons i hear you i hear
o'shea jackson that's why one of the
many reasons the clippers will not win a
championship because they didn't do it
the right way
there's a there's a right way of
building a super team
and still saying oh but we're about to
do it whatever y'all do this is about me
but you know what it is
and lebron is different okay and it's
honestly
this this is the difference between
success and failures by the way
you know how they say oftentimes the
best trades are the ones you never make
remember the lakers they wanted kawhi
but kawhi would have never
tried to pull let alone get away with
any of this he couldn't have
not only team but check this out though
they're firewalls in place they're
firewalls
experiments that work and a super team
experiments that don't
it's one word culture that culture
you can't import that culture by
acquiring players
you have to have it in place already
high miami
okay high golden state you have to have
it in place
already and then it has to be
established and then somebody comes in
and either adds to it or adopts that
culture
the problem with the clippers is their
entire culture
historically has been one of this
function and he tried to buy it
overnight
by bringing in a guy who had one
elsewhere and another guy who was really
good but hadn't won anything
you bring him in and you roll out the
red carpet and you drop rose petals at
their feet
and you got everything you got wipers
for crying out loud
you know get bathing them that's the
only thing they don't they don't they
didn't get was bathers
okay you give them all of this and lo
and behold
oh my goodness we have a chemistry
problem well of course you have a
chemistry problem
and of course we can cross the clippers
off from contending
not with this group so moving on
and and here's a couple other things too
a couple other things we talk about oh
yeah yeah
you know lebron wouldn't stand up for it
and
in certain places but i'm sorry but
lebron is a traveling culture
where he go he is a different kind of
pie piper so he's difficult
if your culture yes if your culture's
not in place
i'm going to bring my culture with you
which is why if you if you remember this
when he got back to cleveland there was
a little bit of bristling
because he was he was aghast at some of
their practice habits
and kyrie was one of those people
who like oh what are you doing this is
how we do it so he had to bring kyrie up
that's why kyrie
kyrie and kevin durant i'm watching
listen i'm watching
i watch it there's an athletic story
that i got bookmarked too that i want to
read
i want you to break down of that as well
i'm not sure
but uh here's another reason i don't
like what the clippers have done
because paul george ain't that dude he
ain't that dude you don't do this
his teammates recognize that he got into
it with beverly and paul george
because of that it was like who are you
that's that's that's what they said to
him who are you that's why he kept
butting heads that's why they rolled
their eyes reportedly
yeah it's gonna be interesting man it's
gonna be interesting to see how this uh
how this plays out and what happens
after because i keep
did we have this conversation about okc
did i say
hey can you win a championship so we
talk about this
because eventually probably yeah but
eventually the clippers are going to
dissolve
like they usually do okay that's going
to be over
and i say lebron can play forever but
lebron is 36.
you start looking around the league and
okc is just going to be sitting there
with this
all this capital i got money around me
look at all this money look at all this
money
what are you going to do with it they
draft well
they make good trades
what we got oh i'm sorry it's not
breaking news we can go to break uh
shortly but i just want okay i want to
uh
break this or or put a put a pin on it
well it's not breaking news and i'll be
doing that
george i'm sorry paul george uh
to all the smoke great podcast uh doc
was trying to play me as a ray allen or
jj reddick all pin downs i could do that
but that ain't my game i need some flow
i need some mixes
of some pick and roll and post-ups that
last season was hard
um okay look look ty lou that's at least
your concerns
based on what you know i'm gonna say uh
just real quick before we uh before we
hit this break
uh i was on a radio station in philly uh
wip
uh earlier and they asked me
about doc and uh you know how's doc
gonna do in philadelphia you know do you
think he can get this into a
championship bunch i
actually think i think he can because
the difference
i told the host says the difference
between doc
and boston and doc and the clippers
especially this last clippers team i'm
talking about
is in boston they bought into him they
bought in
like they just doc said it they like we
got you doc we believe they believed him
and they never they didn't buy in this
group did not buy in a dock
the boston group did and i think the
philly group will
and and now you're going to see what
philly is all about it's philly a
perfect team no but i think you'll get
the maximum
out of what's there okay that that's
what doc has been known for
uh but well he was known for that in
boston he was known for that
in in la before ironically before
kawhi and and george got there remember
they won like 47 games
oh yeah no right absolutely but we'll
see if a really good team
yeah we'll see if tyler could succeed
where doc rivers failed uh in la
at least with this iteration of the
clippers hey thanks for watching brother
from another on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you